once a hub of french aristocratic  parties this castle on the countryside  lies abandoned after falling victim to a  house fire  [Music]  a few hours outside paris are the  remains of the chateau de lemont chander  nien  the castle was built in the 14th century  and was owned by french nobles  it was conquered twice by the british in  the middle ages and was devastated  during the french revolution  around 60 years later after a wealthy  relative of napoleon iii took control he  restored the castle to its former glory  however in 1932 just after central  heating was installed a violent fire  broke out  since the fire the castle has been  slowly taken over by nature trees have  grown through the interior and vines  crawl along the once sturdy castle walls  though its fate is still uncertain today  there are efforts to save the castle  with the group raising money to restore  the ruins  [Music]  you